malgré un soleil radieux les rues de
saint germain des prés affiche une
triste mine
en plein coeur de paris ce quartier de
la rive gauche
habituellement très fréquentés par ces
riverains et les touristes et pour la
période anormalement calme un manque
d'activité qui impacte fortement les
restaurateurs et les hôteliers les
réservations sont en chute libre
alexis teyssèdre propriétaire et
directeur de l'hôtel du pas de calais
craint que la période qu'il est en train
de traverser s'étendent jusqu'à la
rentrée prochaine pour le mois de
septembre
comme vous pouvez voir sur ce planning
également on est en un taux d'occupation
aujourd'hui qui avoisine les 27 28 %
sachant qu'on est le 20 juillet et que
normalement à cette date d'occupation
pour septembre devrait être entre 50 et
55 % donc ça veut dire qu'on est
quasiment deux fois moins que d'habitude
et sachant que une grande majorité des
gens qui sont dans ce planning de
réservation sont des gens qui sont en
dehors de l'europe
donc ça veut dire que si jamais il ya
des restrictions sanitaires ou quoi que
ce soit mon planning sera vide en
septembre si la question du pain
solitaire n'est pour le moment pas une
source d'inquiétude pour ce directeur
d'hôtel il est urgent que le
gouvernement apporte des solutions à
tous les hôteliers de france aujourd'hui
nous réclamons d'urgence
la prise de conscience du gouvernement
français sur la situation des hôtels
parisiens
aujourd'hui les étrangers ne sont pas là
et paris accueille principalement des
étrangers
or sans ces gens là ne pouvons pas vivre
ça fait 18 mois que nous ne faisons plus
de chiffre d'affaires donc si le
gouvernement ne met pas en place des
aides pour nous aider à passer ce cap
nous ne pourrons pas survivre et nous
nous pourrons les hôtels indépendants
vont disparaître autres conséquences
liées à cette baisse d'activité
les employés qui n'ont pas encore
déserté la profession sont pour la
plupart de nouveau contraints au chômage
partiel est retourné à la maison encore
faire des deux jours des jours des mois
des mois la maison sans rien faire
tourner ou même pièce non non ce n'était
pas la santé j'avais pas des problèmes
de santé mais les fait que de rester
chez moi tout le temps tout le temps il
y avait un moment
ras-le-bol quoi mais face à la situation
désastreuse dans laquelle se trouvent
les établissements parisiens
nombreux sont ceux qui comme l'autel du
pas de calais ne pourront échapper à une
fermeture temporaire
maintenant c'est désormais une certitude
nous allons fermer au moins deux cas
des 8 août le telle affaire même pas
fermé nous avons tout fait pour éviter
cela mais malheureusement faute de
demande
comme j'ai pu le voir sur les plannings
nous sommes obligés de fermer à partir
de 8 août pour une durée indéterminée
d'après un sondage mené auprès du
groupement national des indépendants de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration à paris
et en ile de france
faute de réservations 70% des hôtels
parisiens seront fermés au mois d'août